how about the mayor of Portland I feel
like this guy he had a little bit of a
rough night now this is the thing it
depends on what reality you inhabit the
reality of reality or the reality of
what's become unfortunately sort of just
left wing narratives and even him him
saying like he saw nothing out there
here's here's here see this is our Ted
wheeler you had wheeler the mayor of
Portland and it's a tweet from a guy
named Andy NGO I don't want to say it
he's up so here he is with the
protesters getting teargas
he's surrounded by a heavy heavy
security detail because you know he's
with his people so this is him getting
tear gassed he's a heavy heavy detail
and then let's look at some of the other
videos I mean he's a liberal [ __ ] too
right as liberal as you can get and
here's him here's what he says happened
he sees nothing wrong I can tell you
with a hundred percent honesty I son not
which provoked this response
okay I'm not a great so there you go
he's saying it's peaceful protest he see
nothing that's provoked this response
from the federal agents and now let's
look at some other footage of what of
what is the protesters had to say to him
because they welcomed him with open arms
let's listen to it Mikey oh god there's
been a tear
[Applause]
yeah they just barely got a man to
safety before he was attacked they were
throwing [ __ ] at the door so that's how
much they loved him now let's take a
peek if we can binky at some of the the
footage of what's happening in Portland
yeah there we go
there we go so there's there doing
nothing to provoke this response yeah
who's there hungry that's why that's why
they're doing it yeah but I mean it's
just peaceful protests I'm sure these
guys got permits and yeah there's fires
I had the federal agent set those fires
over there and they're trying to break
into the federal courthouse here's the
deal guys
federal aid there's some more footage of
some of the peaceful protests look it's
nice we roast marshmallows yeah I mean
there's footage the footage is endless
it's generous the media has access to it
they're not saying anything federal
agents
constitutionally have the right to
protect federal property they do not
have to ask the city or state government
they just can swoop in and protect the
federal property I think that they've
done in my opinion I think the federal
government has done a good job and by
they haven't killed anybody yet I just
think at some point I mean there's some
point they're gonna get an order to
start shooting live rounds of people if
they keep burning buildings down
unfortunately that's the reality that
we'll get to which is like civil war
[ __ ] well that's the problem and that's
why I think that's what I was gonna say
before that's a little bit of why the
police are kind of standing down right
because they know there's nothing they
can do if they because you can't just
ask a suspect to just stop I mean they
don't some often it has to come to some
sort of struggle or you know so it's
like they know that they're always gonna
be in the wrong so they're going like
what am I supposed to [ __ ] do and here
it's like everyone nobody's saying
anything about these right those are
rioters and it's sad too because
lieutenant lollipop and Sergeant
snuggles like you could go inside your
service but because I have a chest
injury
I can't even deescalate the way I wanted
to escalate cuz I got any I'm on the IR
right now ya know we got to get in there
and we got to start tickling some balls
to stop it it's the only thing cause I
give like kisses on everybody's
bellybutton and then we'll see if they
want to keep doing rocks we'll see we'll
see what
we'll see what happens then [ __ ] know
what you say you said you were to kiss
peoples buttholes yeah I will [ __ ] no
kissing mani ass cheeks I wanna ask you
see yeah I want to tickle I want to
tickle I want to tickle feet
I want to tickle feet I don't want to I
wanna I wanna I want to blow on balls is
what I want to do let's remove the skin
tag from my ass cheek live on the
patreon later promise let's turn you
into a superhero called ask me will you
ask and you just come and you rot in
your ass just hits protesters out of the
way yeah um
Kanye West has been spotted shopping for
kids clothes out of Wyoming Walmart so I
mean unfortunately if you're a West kid
now you get your clothes at Walmart
cause daddy's went off the reservation
yeah I mean need if you're a Kardashian
you have no idea what's going on in the
world these guys live you know in a
Hollywood bubble they don't even I don't
even think they listen to the news they
got no I the kid is the kid so here's
the deal is he promoting the album is
eclectic so I think he ran for president
to promote an album that's generally
what I believe and I believe that he's
insane and the Kardashians are behind it
all pulling the strings and that's truly
what I think now and it's you know I
don't know if I'm right but it seems
like a lot of people are gonna be
interested in his album now right well
yeah I'm gone down you don't have to be
a conspiracy stairs to see that the
release date being July 24th and this
will happen right before it's a little
bit of a coincidence it's a it's what I
call in Ridgewood a co-inky-dink it's a
little bit of a coin key now you're
gonna get the album on because Kanye
West he could spit yeah I mean Kanye
West running for president and saying
all that crazy stuff about Kardashian
and Ray J or whatever cuz I don't let my
brain remember that stuff whatever he
said it's kind of like us releasing a
Bay Ridge boy trailer saying there's
more to come
that's me Kanye go and there's more to
come thank you guys so much for watching
we hope you loved it don't forget to
click Subscribe and turn your alerts on
and go to patreon.com/crashcourse for
more fun where things get really bad
[Music]